it's amazing hi my name is Yvonne Liam
I'm really happy to be here this is
actually the first time being at this
conference and also um really excited to
report that I will be a night fellow at
Stanford this fall but before that
before that the Associated Press and
before that I mean then after that I
decided to join this newsroom startup
called digital first media's projects
under dome yes for those who are not
familiar it is a newspaper group but we
secrete it the startup within it and
today I want to talk about how to
survive a newsroom implosion thank you
Nieman lab for the term but essentially
Thunderdome is over it's completely gone
and these are kind of the lessons that
I've learned from going through that
experience so project Thunderdome
generates long Mad Max and there's this
saying two men enter one man leaves I
would highly recommend to not do that
when you're trying to go through a
newsroom implosion in fact I would do
the opposite I would try and stick
together I think that's a really
important thing for our newsroom I think
that was one of the best things about
the culture is that when everything is
starting to hit the fan you still have
these relationships and though that's
really what's going to bring you into
the next level and kind of cultivate
that kind of community so definitely
stick together it's not one woman for
herself and it's really hard it's really
easy to say just forget it but then one
of the things that we actually did in
the process community fans community
friends thank you build a safe house and
what I mean by that is when we were
going through all of this turmoil we
were talking on skype we had slack
groups we had a Facebook group we had a
Google group we were always talking to
one another and supporting one another
doing well editing resumes doing
headshots for each other reviewing
portfolios and that type of experience
is very enriching and on top of that
it's just embrace your strengths this is
a really key moment when you've lost
your job
you don't know what's going on trying to
figure out exactly what you want to do
again and don't rush yourself and try
and figure out you know what's the next
step because it's really easy to
second-guess yourself especially when
there's rounds of layoffs and like me I
was the first round and you kind of
question your abilities and it's very
emotionally unstable and insecure but
that's the process you don't have to be
a victim of it so I can we spread the
word hopefully there's some office fans
to spread the word let people know that
what has happened is actually not a
result of your doing but it's just
situational and circumstantial at some
extent and it's very easy to just say
you know this is kind of embarrassing I
think that's you have to push against
that stereotype or that mentality and
really let people know that you're
looking for new opportunities that this
has happened because I think we'll all
be pleasantly surprised by what happens
next when they we reach out to you and
then interviewing talking to people
those informational interviews coffee
shops and meeting and grabbing coffee
people take the long view because at the
end of the day could be a numbers game
and that type of cultivation takes a
long time to kind of figure out what's
next
but again it's you're very emotionally
vulnerable and secure just being back on
the market again not really sure what's
going on and it wasn't of your doing so
you kind of have to play with the
punches and see how it goes the other
day be sure to pay it forward I think
that's something that's easily
overlooked because you're taking in all
of these and words of encouragement all
the support definitely make sure that
you're also trying to pay it forward in
helping people along the way in their
careers because surviving and user
implosion isn't just a singular
experience a lot of people go through a
lot of layoffs especially in our
industry so last but not least
anticipation anticipation anticipation
make sure that you are also trying to
seize the moment and really kind of
embrace what it's like even when it
feels like things are hitting the fan
and so dance and that really is just
kind of you know taking a break enjoying
it while also realizing that this is not
the ideal situation but its life and
life will always have ups and downs and
just dance listen to music have Joyce
play for you and just kind of an embrace
the situation go spend time with friends
relax and I think having that anxiety
off of you you'll do a lot better so how
does vive a newsroom implosion thank you